hi this is Mario with Mario's math
tutoring coming to with another math
video to help you boost your score in
your math class improve your
understanding and hopefully make
learning math a lot less stressful so
what we're going to talk about in this
video is how to find the area of a
sector using proportions so what is a
sector basically what a sector is it's a
section ok of the entire circle so it's
like a pizza slice or a pie slice of the
circle and you just want to find the
area of that little slice without
actually having to find the area of the
entire circle and so what we're do is
we're going to make a proportion we're
going to compare the central angle theta
divided by 360 equals the area of the
sector divided by the entire area of the
circle PI R squared okay that's the
formula for the area of the entire
circle so basically the way this works
is you're taking the part divided by the
whole see the theta is the fraction of
the entire 360 degrees and then you're
taking the area of the sector which is a
fraction of the entire area of the
entire circle so you're doing the part
over the whole equals apart over the
whole right and you make a proportion
you can cross multiply and solve for the
missing quantity so let's take a look at
an example so here we're trying to find
the area of this pizza slice okay this
sector section of a circle and so what
we're gonna do is we're gonna make a
proportion we're going to say 60 degrees
divided by 360 degrees that ratio that
fraction is the same as the area of the
sector we'll just call that a divided by
the area of the entire circle PI R
squared and the radius is 3 so all we
have to do now is cross multiply but
before I do that I'm going to simplify
this fresh and just reduce it down a
little bit and I'm going to simplify
this this comes out to 9 pi so if we
cross multiply we get 6a equals 9 pi
divided by 6 and you can reduce this
down but this is going to come 2 3 PI
over 2 inches squared okay because it's
area so square units so this is how you
find the area of a sector using a
proportion and I hope that helped you to
understand a lot better so subscribe to
the channel check out some of my past
videos and I'll see in the next video
I'll talk to you soon